فضيحه الاطفال اللاجئين المفقودين من
فنادق بريطانيا هزه الراي العام وارغمت
وزير الهجره على تقديم احاطه عاجله للنواب
للكشف عن عدد المختفين والاجراءات المتبعه
لتعاقبهم
ان اي حاله اختفاء تفاعل بروتوكول الاشخاص
المفقودين الذي يشمل وكاله متعدده بما
فيها الشرطه والسلطات المحليه لتحديد مكان
وجودهم والتاكد من سلامتهم
88% من الاطفال اللاجئين المفقودين غير
مسحوبين بذويهم من البانيا والبقيه من
افغانستان ومصر والهند وفيتنام وباكستان
تركيا
6400 طفل غير مسحوبين بدويهم في الفنادق
منذ يوليو 2020 كانت هناك 440 حاله مفقوده
ولا يزال مائه طفل في عداد المفقودين 13
منهم دون سن السادسه 10 وحاله واحده فقط
لفتاه
حزب العمال المعارض من جهته هاجم الحكومه
متهما اياها بالفشل في منع العصابات
الاجراميه من استهداف هذه الفنادق ودور
الاطفال رغم تحذيرات الشرطه وزاره
الداخليه تريد انهاء استخدام الفنادق في
اقرب وقت ممكن خصوصا بعد مطالبه السلطات
المحليه بتامين الرعايه الكامله للاطفال
اللاجئين في بيوت وضمان حمايتهم فيما تعمل
الوزاره على اصلاحات او ساعه لنظام اللجوء
ليكون عادلا وفعلا من اجل الصالح العام
كما تقول مصطفى زاروه العربيه لندن